ce mardi soir pour le match de l'équipe
de france de football contre la croatie
en ligue des nations les bleus vont
porter un nouveau maillot depuis leur
premier match en 1904 les français ont
arboré plusieurs couleurs et une seule
fois le vert en 1978 suite à un incident
très particulier
voilà les l'image du tas de mar del
plata
l'arrivée avec 10 juin 1978 coupe du
monde en argentine l'équipe de france
est sur le point d'affronter la hongrie
à mar del plata à 14h30
mais à quelques minutes du coup d'envoi
français et hongrois n'ont toujours pas
fait leur entrée sur le terrain
le journaliste michel drucker commencent
à s'inquiéter le match est prévu le coup
d'envoi est prévu dans trois minutes et
je crois que c'est la première fois
depuis début du tournoi que les
organisateurs à 14h30
le match n'a toujours pas débuté dans
les tribunes journalistes et spectateurs
s'impatiente
les photographes au bord du terrain
aussi un homme fait même un peu de
ménage à l'entrée du tunnel des joueurs
michel drucker tente de combler comme il
peut à peine après 25 minutes d'attentes
toujours rien c'est l'inquiétude dans le
stade
alors pourquoi autant de retard michel
drucker vient d'avoir l'explication
avait compris pour une première note des
deux types qu'elle veut et qu'elle
devait leur maillot blanc dont dépend
téléphoner avec des maillots blancs en
réalité la note avait été mal
interprétée car annulée par une seconde
note les maillots rouges les français en
blanc les hongrois aussi pour éviter
toute confusion
les bleus vont emprunter des maillots
verts et blancs à une petite équipe
locale le club atlético kimberley
finalement le match débute avec 35
minutes de retard sous les sifflets du
public à la fin du match
la france n'en porte 3 buts à 1 sur des
réalisations de lopez berdoll et
rocheteau
depuis cette rencontre la france n'a
plus jamais évolué en vert et blanc
[Musique]